Ciao maryners e benvenuti  nella mia  cucina ma soprattutto a una nuova puntata di una youtuber in cucina!
Oggi prepareremo una torta
Buonissima che io adoro ma che adora soprattutto Salvo, infatti per il suo compleanno
gli ho fatto la sorpresa perché gli ho preparato la sua torta preferita
Era la prima volta che la facevo ed è venuta
Buonissima e quindi mi avete visto nelle delle stories mentre la preparavo e le foto eccetera eccetera mi aveva chiesto di farvi vedere
Come si prepara la New York cheesecake ai frutti di bosco!
quella che preparerò oggi insieme a voi e la cheesecake proprio, originale quella cotta
Nel forno ed è veramente squisita quindi e ci sono tante ricette in giro ma questa
È la mia preferita! Partiamo subito con gli ingredienti che ci servono per la nostra cheesecake
Allora, per la base abbiamo bisogno di 200 g di biscotti secchi, io vi
io vi consiglio i digestive che sono perfetti per questa tipologia di torta
100 g di burro, per la crema invece 600 grammi di philadelphia
150 g di yogurt greco,  120 grammi di zucchero, 3 uova
una bustina di vanillina e il succo e la buccia di mezzo limone non trattato mi raccomando. Per la decorazione
invece ci servono 200 grammi di frutti di bosco 2 cucchiai di zucchero
E un cucchiaio di succo di limone. Iniziamo preparando la base, quindi metto i 100 g di burro a sciogliere in un pentolino
Dopo di che dobbiamo frantumare
i nostri biscotti, per comodità io li metto solitamente dentro un sacchettino, come questo
mi aiuto  con un mattarello e li sfrantumo per benino perché devono essere appunto sbriciolati
quindi, mettiamo qua dentro
magari prima iniziamo con le mani, o diamo  qualche colpo così, è anche diverte!
Poi quando sono un pochino più sbriciolati allora inizio a passare il mio mazzarello, vedete? E automaticamente si sbriciolano
Una volta frantumati i nostri biscotti e
Dobbiamo procurarci una tortiera di 20 centimetri possibilmente, potete anche usarne una un po
Più grossa però sappiate che la cheesecake poi non verrà bella alta, ma verrà sottile.
Io per esempio uso  questa a forma di cuore che è super cute! E ricordatevi di
Prendere un foglio di carta da forno e posizionarlo sulla base, vedete come ho fatto io.
Quindi versiamo i nostri biscotti frantumati in una ciotola
Prendiamo il nostro il burro che abbiamo fatto sciogliere e lo versiamo sopra
per poi mescolare chiaramente il tutto
e andare a creare la nostra base
Mescoliamo bene
Dopo aver mescolato bene versiamo il tutto dentro la nostra tortiera che mi raccomando non l'ho detto prima ma deve essere apribile
e soprattutto dobbiamo premere bene per creare appunto alla base quindi
Perché non ci siano dislivelli cerchiamo di con un cucchiaio magari ci aiutiamo e la combattiamo bene
Mi stai riprendendo? Sì, ti sto riprendendo!
Ecco qua la nostra base, la teniamo in frigo la mettiamo in frigo e apriamo per 15 minuti, in modo tale che  si raffreddi
Passiamo subito alla crema
Vi ricordo che la ricetta originale americana prevede l'uso della panna acida che però in italia è abbastanza difficile da trovare e quindi
Il sostitutosecondo me più adatto è lo yogurt greco che si trova ovunque
cominciamo
Versando appunto la crema spalmabile la philadelphia, mi raccomando 600 grammi nè uno in più
Né uno in meno. Una volta versato il formaggio spalmabile
Aggiungiamo anche I 120 g di zucchero e mescoliamo bene
Facciamo amalgamare il tutto
Dopo aver mescolato crema spalmabile e zucchero procediamo con la scorza del mezzo limone
Mi raccomando attenzione alle unghie perché se vi grattate anche il gel potrebbe essere un problema
E dopo aver grattugiato il vostro limone
aggiungete anche
Il succo sempre di questo mezzo limone.
Passiamo ad aggiungere lo yogurt greco che ricordo è il sostituito alla panna acida che mettono in America
Aggiungiamo le 3 uova 1, 2
e 3
Ultimo ingrediente per la nostra crema è la bustina di vanillina
Sì ad aprirla
Perfetto, adesso
Prendiamo un bello sbattitore elettrico perché tutta la forza di girare non ce l'ho e
mescoliamo il tutto
Siete pronti?
1,2,3
Ma sta schizzando tutto!
mi sa che dopo dovrò pulire, ma vabè. Okay, questo è un fuori onda. Buono!
Ho tirato fuori dal frigo la nostra base, scusate il casino, ma come avete visto è schizzato un po' tutto. È arrivato il momento di
versare la nostra crema che pesa un sacco e
la versiamo
sulla nostra base
Pesava un sacco, mamma mia. Le vere cheesecake americane
Una volta ottenuto questo fantastico risultato andiamo a infornare la nostra cheesecake  nel forno a 180° gradi e la facciamo cuocere
per 50 minuti
Ci siamo è arrivato il momento di
togliere dal forno la nostra fantastica cheesecake
attenzione quando la
sollevate perché rimane molto morbida quindi è facile insomma che si apra, che si rovini.
Questo è l'aspetto che deve avere la vostra cheesecake una volta
tolta dal forno e come potete vedere
bella dorata nel contorno e invece giallo canarino nel mezzo, ma
mentre la facciamo raffreddare un attimo
Ho messo I 200 g di frutti di bosco, 2 cucchiai di zucchero e del succo di limone a cuocere in un pentolino
Creeremo così la copertura. Il topping di questa cheesecake che è il passaggio finale
per poi proseguire
All'assaggio che è la parte che mi piace di più.
Una volta tolti dal fuoco e nostri frutti di bosco che hanno insomma creato questa salsina un po' liquida e con alcuni pezzi
insomma
interi,  l'andiamo a
versare
sopra la nostra cheesecake.
Perfetto
Allora la lasciamo raffreddare un pochino fuori,  dopodichè la metterei in frigo per un'oretta
Perché penso che la cheesecake sia meglio gustarla fredda. In questo modo possiamo anche
Far sì che la salsina, il topping della nostra cheesecake si solidifichi un attimo e quindi
sia
Perfetta la nostra cheesecake. La nostra New York cheesecake!